there was a host on msnbc tiffany cross  who attacked bill maher bill maher is a  liberal  uh but he's a white guy this is a black  woman saying that that white man  needs to shut his mouth  okay bill maher has been whack for a  long time bill maher you do not get to  tell people of color what they should or  should not be offended by stay in your  lane slim try that instead of standing  on your alabaster perch every week to  crap on other people's lived experience  while providing a safe haven for  well-established white supremacists  because i gotta tell you this old angry  white man act is so played  whoa man this woman is a vile vile  racist right do you i mean i know the  word racist doesn't mean anything  anymore because the left has watered it  down to mean nothing  but if racist means anything it means  that woman